[Music]
on the edge of North America the
Canadian Arctic is breathtaking
and brutal
Sailors with the Royal Canadian Navy are
used to contending with life at Sea
and they'll break off a little bit
but these waters are some of the most
unforgiving on Earth
navigating the Arctic Ocean takes
careful coordination
Commander Nicole robichow has been in
the Navy for 20 years
recently taking the Helm of a new ship
hmcs Margaret Brook
the mission to boldly go where no
Canadian Patrol ship has gone before
well we're here to prove that we can
operate in the north and we can operate
with our our partners so I think that
goes and shows a lot to our other
friends or foes that may be around
this frigid Frontier is a training
ground
Northern navies from Canada the United
States Denmark and France working and
sailing together as part of operation
Nook
it's an annual exercise in Arctic
security
and this year there's a sense of urgency
a global power struggle for control of
this region is heating up the sea ice is
melting making the Arctic more
accessible and creating massive economic
and political waves
over his career Mark LaRoche has spent
nearly 2 000 days at Sea the most of
anyone on the crew he's watched this
landscape change
it's the north it's a place we never
really paid attention because it was
self-protected by the ice we kind of
took it for granted
LaRoche is the head engineer on hmcs
Margaret Brook
he joined the Navy as a teenager 32
years ago after watching a documentary
about the Franklin Expedition the doomed
19th century Voyage to find the prized
passageway from Atlantic to Pacific
I come from a small farming community
and pretty much that's what wasn't in
store for meat farming that documentary
kind of was really the first time I
really thought about life at Sea and
being a sailor and that's pretty much
where everything started for me the
dream of traveling through the Northwest
Passage was impossible
Franklin's fabled route was locked under
the Arctic Ice
until now
hmcs Margaret Brook is one of six new
Canadian icebreakers capable of cutting
through ice a meter thick
the fleet is tasked with patrolling the
Arctic an area that spans 40 percent of
Canada's territory including the entire
length of the Northwest Passage for the
first time this platform really did open
up the north didn't
need we never really had the capability
to come here
the Arctic itself is changing warming
more than twice as fast as the global
average the melting ice is opening up
new lucrative shipping lanes in the
Northwest Passage and unearthing buried
Treasures natural resources long hidden
are now within reach as it becomes more
accessible to us it's also more
accessible to other countries so we want
to make sure that other countries
understand that Canada will enforce
through the law in its Arctic including
the defense of our territory Captain
Sheldon Gillis is the Canadian task
group Commander for operation Nanook the
concern if Canada doesn't assert its
ownership of this region another Nation
will so whether to Russia or any other
country they need to know that this is
Canadian territory and their Armed
Forces will enforce that sovereignty on
behalf of Canadians
Russia has been rapidly ramping up its
military presence in the Arctic holding
exercises reopening cold war bases and
building hundreds of new structures
Russia's Northern Fleet covers Land Air
and Sea from nuclear-powered missiles
and Torpedoes submarines to fighter jets
that growing military footprint took on
new urgency
when Russia invaded Ukraine the threat
environment facing North America
including Canada is more serious than it
was before this would be one route there
are multiple routes to the Northwest
Passage Whitney lockenbauer is one of
Canada's foremost experts on Arctic
history and security he says the Arctic
had long been a beacon of geopolitical
cooperation but Russia's War has cast a
chill Russia is an increasingly
uncertain unpredictable actor globally
which means it affects Canada and it is
an increasing risk to North America
lochenbauer points to competing claims
between Canada the United States and
Russia for resource-rich regions of the
Arctic Ocean the U.S Geological Survey
estimates the Arctic holds 13 of the
world's undiscovered oil and a third of
its undiscovered Natural Gas
it's here at the Arctic Council where
disputes have traditionally been
discussed the Arctic is a region for
strategic competition has seized the
world's attention the body made up of
eight Northern Nations and Indigenous
groups was suspended indefinitely after
Russia invaded Ukraine this leaves some
questions about our ability to actually
have conversations as a community of
Arctic countries but lockenbauer says a
disagreement over ownership of Arctic
resources is unlikely to spark an armed
conflict anytime soon the Beaufort has
known energy resources the U.S and
Canada have banned offshore drilling in
Arctic Waters and resource extraction in
the far north can be prohibitively
expensive the greater risk at least in
the short term he says isn't a fight for
the Arctic but rather a fight through
the Arctic if the U.S and Canada were
ever drawn into a direct conflict with
Russia the shortest route for Russian
missiles to strike North America
would be from the North Pole and it's
very possible we wouldn't see them
coming there are new threats that are
emerging we don't have the capacity at
present to be able to detect never mind
be able to deter and then defeat
this is Canada's Arctic defense and
surveillance system old and practically
obsolete
known as the north warning system a
chain of 47 radar sites stretching
across the 70th parallel from Alaska to
Greenland first built back in the 1950s
for the Cold War designed to detect old
Soviet bombers the last time that we
modernized NORAD was 1985. would you use
a computer from 1985 to do your job let
alone trying to assure the protection of
the entire Canadian State Rob Hubert is
an Arctic security expert at the
University of Calgary he says the north
warning system is no match for Russia's
high-tech Arsenal
like Hypersonic missiles which can
travel many times the speed of sound
have featured prominently in Russia's
war in Ukraine we also face the
existential threat of the Russians
increasingly talking about the use of
nuclear weapons that is where the
Russians have the bulk of their nuclear
forces station and so the Arctic becomes
the battlefield
back on board hmcs Margaret Brook the
crew finds themselves in a tight spot
the Arctic Patrol vessel is about the
size of a football field attempting to
squeeze through this narrow passage just
one kilometer wide
the bellet straight sits on the
northernmost edge of Mainland North
America and these are uncharted waters
we know where the land is by grace of
satellite imagery but what's under the
water is still very mysterious in some
places the ship's navigating officer
Lieutenant Graham Austin says the
melting Arctic Ice is revealing new
Roots where the depth currents even
weather patterns are often unknown if
the strait had been somewhere like
Vancouver Harbor we would know exactly
how fast the water was moving and what
time and what direction whereas up here
we might not have any idea if there's
100 meters or 500 meters or one meter of
water so it's all hands on deck teams
checking and double checking their
trajectory low-lying rock you can see it
red one zero will others scan for
icebergs even for this Arctic Patrol
ship ice that's more than a meter thick
or old than compact could breach the
hull start with zero seven eight a
delicate dance where one false move or
miscalculation can spell disaster
you don't want to Hot Dog your way
through a uh a Transit like that without
doing the research and having as much
prior planning as you can for a crew
tasked with patrolling a vast network of
unfamiliar waterways
their best lifeline is local knowledge
the Navy is see help from those who know
the north best
[Music]
indigenous peoples in Canada's Northern
Communities have been stewards of these
Waters and this land for Generations
they've also seen firsthand how climate
change is reshaping the region
the community of Cambridge Bay perched
on the western edge of the Northwest
Passage was once impassable because of
ice
the Inuit Hamlet of 1700 people is now
visited by cruise ships through the
summer carrying more tourists than there
are residents it's been busy but they
all come at the same time me Ali
demetric runs a local transportation
business I know some of the passengers
that we met yesterday were from the
states mostly and I'm not sure where
this one came from I haven't had a
chance to meet anyone yet
hmcs Margaret Brook is patrolling and
policing that growing Maritime traffic
with the help of local communities
Emily Joss is a member of the Sault Ste
Marie historic metis community
she holds a newly created position
within the Navy indigenous liaison
officer we've actually been able to have
conversations with people about like
what it's going to look like when we get
there what parts do we need to avoid and
that comes from just like generations of
local knowledge right and that's uh
incredibly valuable insight for US
soldiers with operation the Nook are
also working with the Canadian Rangers a
mainly indigenous unit of army
reservists in the north making
connections and sharing information for
us it's an incredibly important
relationship you know not just that it's
the right thing to do but also they're
incredible Navigators and environmental
stewards and when it comes to National
Security
including Russia's growing Arctic Shadow
Northern Communities have an important
role to play with the eyes and the ears
of the the north Harry Flaherty is the
chair of nasituk the Inuit owned company
is responsible for operating and
maintaining Canada's North warning
system
47 radar sites including this one in
Flaherty's home city of akaluate built
by NORAD decades ago for the Cold War
Flaherty says the sites are showing
their age our facilities are pretty
outdated they're over 20 years old and
most of them are
kind of getting obsolete last summer
prime minister Justin Trudeau toured the
north warning system radar station in
Cambridge Bay during a visit from NATO
Secretary General Yen stoltenberg the
Canadian defense minister also toured
the sites the trip came on the heels of
the government's pledge to spend 40
billion dollars over 20 years to
modernize Canada's Northern defenses it
includes the construction of a new
surveillance system above the 70th
parallel well it was long overdue when
these systems were first built Flaherty
says there was no meaningful
consultation or collaboration with
Northern Communities he hopes this time
will be different right across Canada
from all the way from the West to the
east we have local communities local
Rangers local businesses that knows
what's going on we know the logistics we
know the land we could play a big role
in that area Flaherty hopes the promise
investment in Northern defenses will
also bring badly needed infrastructure
it's a potential win-win for Arctic
security and Northern development says
expert Whitney lockenbauer I see really
important opportunity space between
smart defense Investments and addressing
a lot of the long-standing
infrastructure gaps that exist in the
Canadian North building Arctic runways
for Canadian fighter jets or New Ports
for Navy ships could also serve as
civilian Transportation hubs especially
for fly-in communities
the same goes for cellular
infrastructure helping to connect remote
regions it makes sense where possible to
also allow communities to benefit from
these Investments all of this needs to
be integrated Canada needs to have a
plan to bring this all together and the
time is now the government's recent
funding announcement included an initial
4.9 billion dollars over the next six
years but military sources told Global
News there are significant concerns it's
not new money and will need to be found
from within the existing budget Arctic
security expert Rob Hubert is skeptical
of Canada's commitment there's all sorts
of uncertainty about just how serious
our government is Canada is the liger in
terms of responding within this overall
context we're not really engaging the
northern countries we've almost to a
certain degree being whistling past the
graveyard and hoping no one notices that
we're not doing anything
for the first time in a long time Arctic
security has been forced into the
spotlight that doomsday scenario of a
Russian strike on North America will
still unlikely no longer feels like a
fantasy
we sat down with defense minister Anita
Anand in Ottawa how are you good how are
you to ask how the federal government
plans to keep Canadians safe we'll have
to make sure that we're continuing to
upgrade the current system while
replacing it with this new system which
will ensure that we have our
surveillance moving further and further
north so that we can detect new
technologies in missiles such as cruise
missiles and Hypersonic missiles which
is the new reality for air surveillance
if a Russian Hypersonic cruise missile
were to Target North America from the
north with our current systems today
provide any warning for that sort of
thing well we're working very closely
with our American Allies to ensure
always that our continent is 100 percent
protected but we do know that there is
infrastructure
from Russia that they are moving further
and further north on their territory and
while the threat of an invasion of our
Arctic is very low at the current time
we need to be prepared for any
eventuality within that primary six-year
window the 4.9 billion where is that
coming from that is in part budget 2022
and other funding the money after the
six-year period is largely new money and
that will be four Continental defense
and NORAD modernization so you have you
know the melting sea ice the the Russian
aggression how important is this file
become for you as the defense minister
moving forward climate change is
a threat to our security and so as
the minister of National Defense we make
sure that we are addressing climate
change realities as well as responding
to Global conflicts for example in
Ukraine we are doing whatever it takes
to defend the Arctic
hmcs Margaret Brook Mark LaRoche's
career is coming full circle after three
decades with the Navy this is his final
mission you know you started your career
in the Cold War I guess yeah pretty much
and here we are and how how does how
does that sit with you we have to make
sure that we are certain our presence
there to make sure that people know that
it is our country make sure we're good
stewards of the North
as you know we go through this shift in
climate change and as the Northwest
Passage becomes more navigable there
will be countries coming through there
will be Ships coming through all the
time it obviously reinforces how
critical it is that we're conducting
these sovereignty patrols and that we're
maintaining our own National Security
it's important for Canadians to know
that we are taking an interest in our
Arctic Waters it's important for the
communities up here to go and see us
taking interest in our Arctic
communities we are here to protect our
Northern Waters